Is what was legendary.
Here's literary work showed
signs of brilliance and his
lifestyle made him for a
time amongst the most celebrated artists,
so his age.
Yes,
his spectacular fall was unprecedented,
only equals in modern
times by the disaster.
That was Oj Simpson.
Oh yes.
In this week's biographics,
we are diving into the Algebra righteous
life of the self proclaimed genius
Oscar Wilde.
I'll skip and go flat out.
He Wills Wilde into the weld on October
the 16th 1854 the flamboyance of his
name,
but was a portions of things to come.
His parents,
they were socially prominent
Anglo Irish Protestants,
each where the collective interest say
belief in national politics and take
publishing career of their own.
Oscar's father William was a renounced
physician specializing in the eye and yet
he was a slight on campus to figure
with an ugly beard and a roving eye,
but this absolutely did not
stop him carrying on numerous
affairs throughout his
marriage and he fathered
several illegitimate children.
In contrast to our husband know Oscar's
mother Jane was especially elegant and
statuesque.
She was almost six feet tall
and towered over our husbands.
She was a woman who longed
to make a sensation,
one stating that I should
like to rage through life.
This Orthodox creeping is
too tame for me as well.
You probably guessed that this was the
attitude that that her son would quickly
embrace when Oscar and her
second son was eight months old.
Jean described him as a great
stout creature who minds
nothing but growing fat.
Jane had actually wants to go in a set
to have dressed Oscar and treated him as
a daughter for the first
decade of his life.
That's age nine Oscar,
along with his older brother,
Willie,
was sent to his first score,
the Portora royal boarding
school in Enniskillen foreign,
the Protestant north of Ireland's Oscar
was younger than most of his peers,
though.
At first he was a clips
by his older brother,
but by the time that Willie
was set to leave Portora,
he had been superseded
academically by Oscar.
In fact,
the younger Wilde was intellectually
far ahead of his classmates in 1889 he
recalls,
I always looked upon as a prodigy by my
associates because quite frequently I
would for a wager read a three
volume novel in half an hour,
so please submit.
Used to be able to give an accurate
resume of the plot of the story.
By one I was reading,
I was unable to give.
They fed a narrative of the incidental
scenes and it's the most person in
dialogue.
In 1871 wild won a scholarship to study
classics at Trinity College Dublin.
He arrived down in 1873 at the age of 18
there he was tutors and befriends is by
reverends.
John Pentlands,
Mahathey professor of ancient history.
Mahaffey inspired is be able to be
proficient in Greek and in 1875 he won the
prestigious but lead gold metal in Greek.
Three years later in 1874 Oscar sale
to England's take the examination for a
classic scholarship at Oxford
University while awaiting the results,
he went to London and was dazzled by
his first taste of the metropolis.
After that,
he traveled to a nother
metropolis and that was Paris.
It was there with his mother and brother
that he received news that he had won
his scholarship and had not only one it,
but it achieved the highest
mark of the entire group,
Oscar,
that he absolutely made the
most of his time at Oxford.
It was during this time that he
cultivated his aesthetic sensibilities,
filling his room with lilies and spending
vast portions of his father's money
upgrading the deck or of his room.
It was at this time that he famously said,
I find it harder and harder every
day to live up to my blue China.
Whilst he was never a fan of sports,
but he did enjoy watching others
play crickets and also run.
He developed a reputation for his wit
proclaiming that the only possible
exercises to talk not to walk still,
he was absolutely no pushover.
It is believed that once while in his
room for undergraduates pounced on him to
beat him up and smashes belongings while
they said to have kicked out the first
interloper punched the second does,
he doubled over,
held the third through the end and it's
carried the last back to his own room
and then tossed him on the floor.
Now it was during his time at
Oxford that wilds became a mason.
He adopted the costume,
velvet breaches,
tailcoat white tie and silk hose
that is extravagant lifestyle.
It was ultimately dented in April
of 1876 when his father died.
Even a serious Das behinds Oscar though
he still managed to find a way to
indulge himself with semester holidays
around Europe just prior to his
graduation in 1878 he consult his mother
destroy too with financial worry that
we have genius.
That is something
attorneys can't take away.
Oscar the emerged from Oxford with a
degree and a clear vision of what was in
store in a remarkably
prophetic couple of sentences.
He declared,
God knows I won't be a
dried up Oxford don anyhow.
I can also live without desire.
Fair and pain,
self poised,
self centered and self
comforters are the a poet,
a writer,
a dramatist.
Somehow or other,
I'll be famous and if not famous,
notorious.
In December of 1878 wild moved to London,
he shared a flat with Frank Miles,
a fellow Oxford graduate.
During this time,
he was introduced to many writers,
artists and actors.
He gained a reputation for is where's it
became a favorite dinner guest where he
would espouse his aesthetic values.
He applied for various fellowships and
even trying to become an inspector of
schools.
During all of this,
he was working on his first play,
Vera,
which he privately printed in 1880 vera
was a story of noble socialism set in
19th century Russia,
but it's unfortunately for Wilde's,
the New York and London
producers that he sent the Plato.
They turned it down.
In 81 Oscar published 61 pieces of writing
under the title poems and initial run
of 750 copies.
It's sold out with to further
printing runs being requires.
Meanwhile,
during all of this,
a play by the renowned team of Gilbert
and Sullivan was indirectly making wild
famous.
It was called patients and it was a
lampoon if the aesthetic culture that wild
epitomized the main character was
clearly model on him by June of 1881 wild
status which such that the Prince of
Wales comments as I do not know Mr Wilde
and to not to know Mr
Wales is not to be known.
Despite this ever growing reputation,
wild found himself in
tough financial straits.
He was offered and accepted a series of
lecture tours around America to coincide
with the New York opening of patients.
He set sail on Christmas Eve 1881 to
instruct the new world in the English arts
of Renaissance.
On arrival he told the
New York customs officer,
I have nothing to to clad.
That's my genius,
but don't try this today.
Anyone.
Well,
the Americans,
the were absolutely fascinated by him
and the original schedule was to be
extended repeatedly in order
to meet public demands.
It would last almost a year and it
would even extend to Canada financially.
He did very,
very well out of this tall.
He actually stayed in New York for
two months after the tours ends.
He then briefly returned to London in
January of 1883 before relocating to Paris
where he immersed himself
in artistic circles.
It was at this point that he
made himself over physically.
He had his long flowing locks transformed
into a bowl haircut and to took to
wearing a black overcoat.
This was increased contrast to the
flamboyance colors that he was previously
known for in May of 1883
wild or returned to London,
apparently motivated by his interest
in a woman named Constance Lloyd,
the daughter of a prosperous Lund
and lawyer for the last few years.
Despite here's American earnings is
Oscar have set and money worries,
variety.
Marriage would also solve those problems
while also answering the growing gossip
about his sexual character.
A year long courtship followed with the
marriage taking place on the 29th of
May,
1884 the couple they honeymooned in Paris
and then thanks to his new father in
law's money occupied a
four story house in London.
He then went ahead and had the
place redecorated at huge expense,
which plunged the newlyweds
into immediate debt.
Wild's first child Cyril
was born on the 5th of June,
1885 with Vivian following on November
the fifth 1886 with his writing career
going nowhere,
but he agreed to a British lecture tour
with topics such as the value of art in
modern life,
lecturing and other invitations.
They kept him away from his family home
a lot and during these long absences he
began to surround himself with young men
writing undauntedly of his infatuation
with the beauty of the male form.
He formed an especially close friendship
with a 17 year olds named Robbie Ross
during the late 1880
as well,
bringing in money with occasional book
reviews at Wildworks on his first novel,
the picture of Dorian Gray when the book
was published in a magazine in 1890 it
caused an immediate scandal,
the storyline and involved
a subtly eroticize triangle
of relationships between
three men and it was condemned
by many as being immoral.
Whilst it predicted such an outcome
to having written the following.
In the preface,
there is no such thing as
a moral or immoral book.
Books are well written or badly written.
That is all it was around this time.
The wild was introduced to do a blondes
basket and undergraduates by the name of
Lord Alfred Douglas,
but he was known to his intimate,
says Boise.
Oscar quickly became
obsessed with a 22 year olds.
From this time on,
Oscar saw constants and
his children less often.
He did writings from rented addresses
or hotels usually with Boise and Tome
Boise's father was actually
the marquis of Queensbury.
Yup.
The man who developed the
rules of professional boxing.
He took an immediate and intense exception
to the relationship between his son
and his,
the famous whiles.
I bought it from the actual
aspect of their relationship.
Queensberry was enraged that wilder was
distracting his son from his studies at
Oxford.
When Boise quit his studies in May of
1893 the marquee became determined to
bring wild down,
but it was around this time that wild
finally achieved success on the stage or
woman of no importance,
so pins on April the 19th 1893 to
widespread a claim during its run.
It brought him between 170 and 200 pounds
per week is next play through satire.
An ideal husband was also successful
providing the means for Oscar and Boise to
travel widely and live extravagantly.
The Marquis of Queensbury thought his
son's failure to dig his degree in Oxford.
What was a scandalous waste of time?
He placed the blame squarely
at the feet of wild,
referring it to the relationship as
the most Lutherism and disgusting.
Queensberry began absolutely
hounding the path.
He actually even threatened
to disinherit by seat.
So this the son replied with a telegram.
What are they?
Funny Little Man.
You are Queensberry not surprising.
They didn't like this one bit.
Ends on the 19th of June.
Queensbury burst in on wild at is
tied the street address in London.
He had a bodyguard with him.
Then it's proceeded to threaten bodily
harm unless the relationship ended
immediately.
So what was Boise's reactions all of this?
Well,
he wrote nonchalantly to his father.
I write to inform you that I treat
your absurd threats with absolute
indifference.
The encounter though,
it's unsettled.
Wild who got out of London for several
months going on a holiday with his family
to where then this is where
he works on his latest play,
the importance of being earnest,
but it wasn't before Boise,
unable to stay away,
invited himself along.
And as you might imagine,
this caused a little bit of
tension between Mr and Mrs Wiles,
the importance of being earnest
opens to great applause.
On February the 14th 1895 do weeks later.
It was already a wild success and
in through Oscar Wilde's style,
he began basking in the glow of this.
It was at this that wild calls
in at the lavish Albermarle club.
There he was handed a card
from Queensbury by a port APP.
On this card was scrawled do
Oscar Wilde posing sodomite.
That's Boise's urging wild
when's a Margaret Street
police station to ask for a
warrant for Queens.
Barry's arrest on the grounds of Lidl.
The case came to trial on April the
third prosecuting counsel Leadwood Carson
and put on the stand a 16 year old boy
who claimed had been paid for sex by
wiles.
Carson then went on to dissect
works published by wild revealing.
They're supposed homosexual undertones,
so malady wilds reacts to
this rather serious events.
Well,
he chose to wield his celebrated
wit as his main defensive tool.
He was often funny,
but the implicit
superiority in his position,
it was also damaging in one exchange when
Carson asked whether the affection and
love that is portrayed in the picture
of Dorian gray might lead an ordinary
individual to believe it had
a sort of medical tendency.
Oscar replied,
I have no knowledge of
the ordinary individual,
which didn't exactly inderam to anyone.
Wilds council and Edward Clarke,
we'll say,
made serious miscalculations
that did his clients no favors.
He went over the letters
of the Queensberry had sent
his son in an attempt to
show how crazy the father
had become to the jury.
Though queens breeze volatility was
driven by a paternal regard for Boise's
character as Carson budget.
His clients had one hope alone and that
was simply saving his son on the third
day of proceedings with things not
exactly going brilliantly wild.
He chose not to attend.
This was to prove the most damaging day.
Yet with Carson announcing
that he intended to introduce
saying number of boys
who would testify to shocking
acts performed by Oscar.
Now without consulting his clients.
While it's lie,
a Clark offered to abandon the case.
The defense,
however,
insisted that the original the stamps,
the judge agreed and compelled and
acquittal from the jury Queensberry he was
found not guilty of libel.
Against wiles is it now
been proven that is written.
Accusation of sodomy was not libelous,
but now there was another
important consequence.
It left wild,
highly vulnerable to arrest for sodomy,
which was a crime at that
time in England and well,
this is exactly what happens at
five in the evening of the day,
the libel case was decided.
A summons was issued for
the arrest of Oscar Wilde's.
The charge was committing acts of gross
indecency hiding in the Catagen hotel.
Oscar was urged by Boise and others
to take a boat immediately for France.
Even his wife told him to run.
However,
this just didn't sit right with whales.
He was determined to stand
his ground and declaring,
I shall stay and do my sentence,
whatever it is.
At 6:10 PM do detectives
arrived and to our case,
semi drunk wilds to both street station.
The arrest of Oscar Wilde
caused an absolute sensation.
Any friends that he still
has quickly drifted away,
both of is currently running place.
They were canceled and his
name very quickly became toxic.
Wilder was captain a cell in both street,
which was that in Holloway prison,
Queensbury now administered the low blow
or forcing a bankruptcy sale of Oscar's
belongings helped by a long
list of angry creditors.
By this time,
wild was about $6,000 in debt after
making sure that Oscar had nothing of any
physical value,
Queensberry wrote to a newspaper denying
that he was capable of any sympathy for
wiles.
He stated I've helped to
cut out then destroy shocks.
I have no sympathy for them,
but it felt sorry and wished to put
them out of pain as fast as possible.
The trial,
well,
it ran from the 26th to the 29th of April.
It was extraordinarily explicit
in its illusions to sexual acts.
Many coming from the young men who claimed
to have been partakers various Savoy
hotel employees testified that
they had seen boys in Wilde's bed.
However,
Oscar's council was able to point out
the contradictions in testimonies,
especially those if the rent's boys.
This all meant that the jury,
they were unable to reach a verdict,
but wild he was not out of the woods
as an almost immediate retrial began
between the two trials.
He did manage to secure a bale,
though stiffed conditions were imposed.
He tried to stay at a number of hotels.
I need to be told to teach
that he was unwelcome.
You finally managed to find
lodgings with his brother Willie.
The second trial.
It began on May the 20
seconds at the Old Bailey.
This time after two hours of discussion,
the jury returned with
a verdict of guilty.
The sentence,
all it would be two years of hard labor.
Walter was taken to pens and Phil prison,
the woods in bed in his
cell has sheets and rugs,
but no mattress at 10 parts
was provided for his toilet.
The prison glades.
They were also not exactly
his accustomed style of dress.
While it was also compelled to walk on
a treadmill senselessly for six hours
each day until now to exercise
outdoors for one hour.
He was also forced to make a
postal bags for three whole months.
He had no outside contact and after that
things were not much better with him
only being allowed to write one letter.
The regime was absolutely brutal.
Wildrick calling three
punishments authorized by law,
hunger,
insomnia,
illness.
In September of 1895 he received a visit
from Constance who found the experience
awful more so than any
conception of it could be.
Constance report it that wilds professed
a rejection of his former conduct and
begged her for forgiveness for his
madness during the last three years.
She decided to stands by her
week rather than wicked spouse.
Still she abandoned his name
referring to herself as constants.
Holland.
When Boise heard about Oscar is
rejection of his form of lifestyle.
He was heartbroken.
He wrote,
I am not in prison,
but I think I suffer as much
as Oscar and in fact more.
That was probably not the case
though because I mean prison.
It was obviously pretty rough.
In October,
he actually came down with dysentery.
Then on November the 21st he was
transferred to Redding prison as Clapham
junction station.
He was spat on and
ridiculed by the crowds.
Here are the conditions.
They were improved,
I just duties they were lighter.
He was finally released.
On May the 19th 1896 Oscar was booked
into the hotel sandwich in d app in
northern France,
living off the generosity of the
few friends who had stood by him.
By now,
constants had designed it on divorce
and suffering herself with spinal
paralysis,
had put it off any reunion.
Between June and July of 1897
Oscar wrote his last major work,
the ballad of reading the subjects as
well that was underlining the need for
reform in Britain's prison and
justice systems like in the APP.
It was excruciatingly lonely
for Oscar society at large.
Shuns him and he spent day
after day alone and miserable.
Finally has resolved,
collapsed hymns.
He wrote to Boise inviting
him to come and stay.
They reconciled on August the 28th with
wild bursting into tears at the site of
his one true love.
When Constance heard of
her husband's behavior,
she wrote to him up for bidding and
he return to your filthy insane life.
When he refused to give our Boise,
she cut him off completely.
Once the initial passion subsided,
it became clear that to both wild and
Boise were different than their pretrial
selves.
Boise,
he felt a duty to help wild but
this was no longer tied to love.
On December the third Boise left for
Naples and did not return Oscar's last two
years,
mostly in Paris.
They were pitiful.
He drank hired men and
bagged acquaintances.
They were few constants.
Oland sadly died at age 40 after an
operation on her back on April the seventh
80 98 then in April,
1900 wild went with an acquaintance
named Harold matters to Rome where he
received the pope's blessing.
A month later he was in Paris
and suffering from ill health,
which he attributed to food poisoning.
His skin was irritable and then
frequently came out in rashes.
By September.
It was completely bed ridden on October
the 10th it was operated on for an ear
infection.
The operation,
it did not go well and he got worse still.
He did insist on continuing
to drink absent fan champagne,
I'll November the 25th they diagnosis
of acute inoperable cerebral meningitis
was reached from here on,
Oscar drifted in and out of consciousness
and even sanity at half past five the
following morning at death rattle
began minutes after his demise,
his body actually sort of exploded.
Fluid pouring out of several RF assists.
Oscar Wilde's,
well he died as he had
lived in appropriately,
outrageously and with scans
reference to watch decorum demanded.
So I really hope you found
that video interesting.
If you did,
please do hit that thumbs up button
below and do not forget to subscribe for
brand new videos every
Monday and Thursday.
We've got loads of other
people just like this.
Also check out a couple of videos from
the archives over there on the race and
does it always.
Thank you for watching.
Hello again.
Just jumping in real
quick to add something.
Now that that video was over.
Obviously this is recorded later.
We want to get your opinion on something.
We've made some tee shirts
that go along with this video.
We're thinking about doing it for
other biographics that we put together.
Please do check out the link
in the description below.
We've got some t shirts with Oscar Wilde,
quotes on them.
Do check it out.
Let us know what you
think in the comments.
We'd love to hear from you and
whether you'd like to see more.
Stuff like that.
And again,
thanks for watching.